[Música]
en el último día del g7 Ucrania volvió a
ser la protagonista los presidentes de
las siete naciones se reunieron con
bolonski y le reiteraron su respaldo
aquí f en medio de la guerra con Rusia
Tenemos reporte desde Hiroshima
Ucrania insiste en que sus tropas
todavía están en bakmuth a pesar de que
la milicia Wagner y el Ministerio de
defensa ruso sostienen que ya controlan
toda la ciudad Incluso el presidente
Vladimir Putin felicitó a sus militares
por la toma ampliamos desde el terreno
nueva tregua en Sudán el ejército afirmó
que pactaron un cese al fuego con los
paramilitares que entrará en vigor el
lunes y durará siete días es para
proteger a los civiles y no se habla aún
de una salida negociada a este conflicto
Bienvenidos a las noticias de France 24
Feliz domingo para todos ustedes yo soy
María Clara calle y es un placer
acompañarlos iniciamos esta ronda
informativa hablando del g7 hoy fue el
último de los tres días de la cumbre en
Japón y Ucrania fue el tema central el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
se reunió con su homólogo ucraniano
y anunció un nuevo paquete de ayuda
militar por 375 millones de dólares que
incluye municiones y vehículos blindados
desde Hiroshima la periodista lusa
Medina nos cuenta más
el grupo de los siete reitera su apoyo
Ucrania en el último día de la jornada
de la cumbre coincidieron en que
continuará su compromiso en brindar
asistencia diplomática financiera
humanitaria y militar a Ucrania y
reafirmaron su determinación de
restaurar la paz en Ucrania y mantener
el orden internacional la visita de
selensky buscó dar un mensaje de fuerza
y unión de los líderes para mantener el
orden internacional y reiterar su apoyo
cráneo dos países ausentes del g7 pero
que ocuparon las conversaciones del día
fueron Rusia y China cuando se le
preguntó el Primer Ministro de Japón
fumida sobre su rol con china aseguró
que trabajará en construir una relación
estable basada en el diálogo para
trabajar en los retos internacionales
también hizo énfasis en que Hiroshima
fue la oportunidad para mostrarle a los
líderes las consecuencias de una bomba
atómica nuevamente vimos las principales
avenidas de la ciudad cerradas y repleta
de oficiales para garantizar la
seguridad durante la visita de los
líderes de los países más poderosos del
mundo en el museo de la paz en los
alrededores se observaban pancartas de
civiles pidiéndole a China y a Rusia Que
retiren su apoyo las continuas
actividades de Corea del Norte y en
contra de la Cumbre del g7 tras
catalogarla de imperialista los
ciudadanos de una ciudad sobreviviente
del desastre nuclear Espera que la
Cumbre no se quede en acciones escritas
en un papel
Mientras tanto en Ucrania hay versiones
encontradas sobre si los rusos ya
controlan o no backmund la milicia
Wagner y el Ministerio de defensa ruso
dan por sentado a su Victoria en la
ciudad pero el ejército ucraniano y el
presidente de bolivian en está Catalina
Gómez Ángel nuestra enviada especial a
Ucrania y Desde allí nos envió el
siguiente reporte
al principio hubo una confusión durante
la presencia del presidente ucraniano en
la Cumbre del g7 en Japón al contestar
una pregunta de los periodistas que
tenía dos partes y se daba por entendido
o alguno lo entendieron así de que él
decía que ya no estaba en control de las
fuerzas ucranianas Esto fue desmentido
rápidamente por su jefe de prensa y por
él mismo en una rueda o en un encuentro
con los periodistas hoy que decía que
las tropas ucranianas seguían teniendo
presencia en esta ciudad por la que los
rusos llevan peleando más de diez meses
y que está totalmente destruida Como así
lo recordaba también el presidente
selensky estas declaraciones iban con en
la misma línea del Ministerio de defensa
de la viceministra que hablaba de que
todavía tenían control de algunas
edificaciones civiles y también
industriales pero Especialmente del
comandante de las fuerzas terrestres de
Ucrania el general Alexander
que si bien tenían el control de una
mínima parte de la ciudad sería
importante de Cara a una ofensiva futura
él hablaba y recordaba que las tropas
ucranianas han venido retomando el
control de territorios en el norte y en
el suroeste de la ciudad y hablaba de
que estas posiciones allí serían
importantes de Cara a un cerco táctico
que es lo que estaría planeando Ucrania
en el futuro Según por lo menos lo que
dice el ejército de este país
cambiamos de noticia para hablar de
elecciones cerca de diez millones de
griegos están llamados a votar en las
parlamentarias de este domingo la
disputa está principalmente entre el
partido Nueva democracia del Primer
Ministro conservador kiriacos mitsutakis
y siritza el principal colectivo
opositor liderado por el izquierdista
Alexis cipras pero el gobierno llega
bajo presión Por las críticas que ha
recibido tras la catástrofe ferroviaria
del 28 de febrero en el que murieron 57
personas veamos una nueva Grecia Esa es
la promesa del Primer Ministro kiriacos
mitsutakis si es reelegido antes de la
votación de este domingo el jefe de
gobierno de derechas insiste en su
balance económico destaca el auge del
sector turístico y la reducción de las
tasas de desempleo tras años de crisis
el ex Primer Ministro al existir cifras
es el hombre que quiere impedirle un
segundo mandato el líder del partido
izquierdista siritza gobernó Grecia
entre 2015 y 2019 su campaña se ha
centrado principalmente en la catástrofe
ferroviaria en la que murieron 57
personas a principios de año Aunque la
economía griega parece haberse
recuperado el país sigue plagado de
problemas como el aumento del costo de
la vida y la escalada de los precios de
la energía no hace poco 50 euros daban
para mucho ahora 50 euros apenas alcanza
para una bolsa o dos de comida y la
calidad no es la misma no podemos
permitirnos lo bueno y yo y sí la vida
sobre todo para los jóvenes es muy
difícil un alto nivel de desempleo no
hay perspectivas de trabajo y se quedan
sin dinero mitad de mes
por primera vez el país utilizará un
sistema de votación de representación
proporcional lo que significa que los
partidos necesitan al menos un 46% para
obtener la mayoría absoluta en el
parlamento de 300 escaños los sondeos
sitúan al actual Primer Ministro en
cabeza por delante de cifras pero lejos
de la mayoría necesaria sin ningún
partido consigue la victoria cada uno
recibirá un mandato de tres días para
formar una coalición para chiriza eso
significaría unirse con al menos otros
dos partidos de izquierdas pero las
opciones son limitadas el partido
comunista ha declarado que rechazaría
cualquier tipo de Alianza y el partido
socialista paso también está reacio a
unir fuerzas si no se acuerda una
coalición Grecia tendrá que celebrar
nuevas elecciones
la segunda vuelta de las presidenciales
en Turquía es el próximo domingo 28 de
mayo los kurdos que representan el 20%
de la población del país están en el
centro de atención de los candidatos
mientras el actual presidente reyeta
Iván intenta atraer el voto de la
extrema derecha y los nacionalistas el
opositor que mallish tiene mayor
respaldo en Villar vaquir Esta es la
ciudad de mayoría curva más grande del
país y ha sido el epicentro del
conflicto entre el estado y los
separatistas kurdos nuestros
corresponsales fueron hasta allí ocho
días antes de las elecciones Esta es la
historia
en Villar vaquera ciudad de mayoría
curva el principal candidato de la
oposición quema el quilice obtuvo uno de
sus mejores resultados con un 72% de los
votos y sus partidarios aseguran tienen
esperanzas para la segunda vuelta
habrá otra vuelta estamos poniendo
banderas en las calles veremos qué pasa
ganaremos si Dios quiere las elecciones
están en la mente de todos y con una
taza de abstención superior a la media
nacional estos jóvenes votantes animan a
todos a depositar su voto el próximo
domingo
el principal objetivo para nosotros en
el kurdistán y en Turquía en general es
crear condiciones para la democracia
para no estar nerviosos todo el tiempo
para no tener que pensar en nuestra
supervivencia todo el tiempo
si nada cambia el 28 de mayo tendré
mucho miedo tendré que salir menos
hablar menos quizás seamos aún menos
libres que antes
esta región abota principalmente al
partido procurdo [__] sus miembros se han
presentado recientemente bajo una
bandera diferente por si intentan
ilegalizar su partido obtuvieron menos
escaños en el parlamento que en 2018
ahora este partido de izquierdas debe
pedir a sus seguidores que voten a un
candidato que ha dado un giro brusco a
la derecha de volver a los sirios a su
país eliminar la amenaza del terrorismo
promesas que suele hacer el partido
gobernante contra los militantes kurdos
este tipo de discurso no se ajusta a los
valores en nuestro partido creo que es
una estrategia de campaña Podría tener
un efecto negativo en los votantes
kurdos pero como la primera vuelta creo
que obedecerán las instrucciones del
partido pero ya sabes sea otro
apoyaríamos a cualquiera contra el
presidente
la coalición ha avanzado
en el poder formó una alianza con un
partido islamista kurdo el uda par
ninguno de sus representantes locales
accedió a hablar con France 24
de Europa nos vamos a África en Sudán
pactaron un nuevo cese al fuego por
siete días según confirmó el ejército
del país pero ni las fuerzas oficiales
ni los paramilitares de las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido hablan de una salida
negociada al conflicto y las treguas
siguen siendo únicamente para no atacar
a los civiles el alto el fuego entraría
en vigor el lunes por la noche hora
local veamos más en el siguiente reporte
los combates siguen causando estragos en
la capital sudanesa hay indicios de un
avance diplomático Estados Unidos y
Arabia Saudita han anunciado un acuerdo
entre las dos facciones enfrentadas en
Sudán es un acuerdo de César fuego de
siete días y se renovará automáticamente
hasta que alcancemos un alto al fuego
permanente está previsto que el alto al
fuego comience el lunes por la noche
hasta entonces el ejército sudanés y las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido han acordado
abstenerse de Buscar ventajas militares
el acuerdo fue negociado por Washington
y real al margen de la Cumbre de la liga
árabe no es el primer alto el fuego que
se anuncia y las treguas anteriores han
sido violadas pero la declaración afirma
que este acuerdo es el primero de este
tipo A diferencia de anteriores cese al
fuego el acuerdo alcanzado en jedi fue
firmado por las partes y contará con el
apoyo de un mecanismo de supervisión del
alto el fuego apoyado por Estados Unidos
Arabia Saudita y la comunidad
internacional tras cinco semanas de
conflicto los enfrentamientos entre el
ejército y el grupo paramilitar fuerzas
de acción rápida han llevado al país a
una situación insostenible los combates
han causado centenares de muertos y más
de un millón de desplazados
en noticias de nuestra región hablamos
del Salvador ayer sábado hubo una
estampida en el estadio de cucastatlán
en San Salvador Hasta ahora se reportan
12 muertos y cerca de 100 heridos la
desbandada se produjo cuando los
aficionados intentaban Ingresar a una de
las zonas del estadio para ver el
partido de fútbol entre el Alianza y el
futbolista asociados santanecos el
presidente nayib bukele anunció que
darán una investigación exhaustiva y la
Policía Nacional explicó lo sucedido en
esa sobresaturación y en esa lentitud de
ingresos se aglomeró un aproximado entre
400 y 500 personas y con el afán de Ver
el partido
algunos aficionados que hicieron abrir
el portón y cuando lo abre y ya se
genera una turba que algunos le llamamos
estampida Pero ya cuando una turba se da
de esa magnitud definitivamente que ahí
las personas algunos cae en otros quedan
debajo el oxígeno empieza a faltar y en
México murieron diez personas durante un
tiroteo en un Rally en Baja California
en el norte del país concretamente el
ataque fue en la ciudad de ensenada y
dejó nueve heridos lo que se conoce
hasta ahora es que personas con armas
largas salieron de una camioneta gris y
comenzaron a disparar contra los pilotos
el fiscal general del estado Ricardo
Iván Carpio comisionó a un grupo
especial para investigar este tiroteo
la Unión Europea dijo estar preocupada
por las suspensiones de candidaturas en
Guatemala y pidió que no se obstruya la
participación el país elegirá al próximo
presidente del 25 de junio y quien
lidera las encuestas por ahora no puede
ser candidato el 19 de mayo el tribunal
de lo contencioso administrativo
suspendió al empresario Carlos Pineda
porque su partido prosperidad ciudadana
cometió presuntamente irregularidades en
la asamblea en la que proclamó a sus
candidatos
pinedales solicitó a la corte
constitucional que revoque la suspensión
ya estoy estoy viendo perseguido por el
estado
Estoy siendo acusado por el estado
estamos en vísperas de una dictadura
estamos ya en una dictadura y en una
dictadura el pueblo es oprimido pero eso
es lo que no queremos en Guatemala
queremos libertad
[Aplausos]
así llegamos al final de las noticias en
France 24 pueden consultar más
información en nuestra página web France
24.com y dejar todos sus comentarios en
nuestras redes sociales donde nos
encuentran como arroba franz24 raya al
piso es nosotros volvemos en minutos
[Música]